Spider-Man is swinging back into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, and it's all because of...
you.
Disney co-chairman Alan Horn and Sony Pictures
chairman Tom Rothman recently took part in
a roundtable discussion in which they agreed
that if not for pushback from fans, this summer's
split which temporarily saw the wall-crawler
ousted from the MCU might have remained permanent.
If you'll recall, Horn and Rothman managed
to hammer out the finer points of a deal which
will allow Tom Holland's Peter Parker to appear
in at least one more solo film set in the
MCU, as well as one additional, as-yet unnamed
Marvel Studios picture.
When it was reported in August that Sony and
Disney, Marvel's parent company, had failed
to reach an agreement to extend their shared
custody arrangement of ol' web-head, fan backlash
was instant and furious and this, said Horn,
was ultimately what convinced the involved
parties to get a deal done.
Horn explained:
"The fan base, which is important to all of
us, seemed to really respond to what Tom and
his folks have done before with our people.
They like the fact that the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and [Marvel Studios head honcho]
Kevin Feige were involved [in Spider-Man:
Homecoming and Spider-Man: Far From Home].
We heard feedback out there that suggested
that joining forces once again was probably
really a good idea."
"Why don't you try that on, and I'll introduce
the world to the newest official member of
the Avengers…
Spider-Man."
Horn, apparently, is a master of understatement.
Twitter absolutely exploded in the wake of
the news that Sony and Marvel were divorcing,
with a large chunk of fans simply beside themselves
with shock and grief.
Holland himself did his best to console them
during an appearance at Disney's D23 expo
the following weekend, and it may have been
during that event that the young star upon
seeing just how much his version of the character
meant to Marvel's fans decided upon a course
of action that few in his position would be
gutsy enough to take.
He reportedly got in touch with Disney CEO
Bob Iger one of the most powerful people in
the world of entertainment and told him in
no uncertain terms that he needed to get Sony
back to the table.
Then, he allegedly put in a call to Rothman
to tell him the same thing.
Improbably, the ploy didn't backfire ridiculously.
Holland kept his job, the two sides got back
together, a deal was struck, and the fans
rejoiced.
Spider-Man is back in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, but now, fans have another question:
for how long?
Are Spidey's days really numbered?
"You are a criminal!
A menace!
And the good people of this nation will squash
you like the bug you are!"
Whether the deal will continue after Spidey
completes his MCU solo film and team-up appearance
is a giant question mark, but given the fact
that there are tons and tons of box office
bucks to be made by keeping fans happy, we
tend to think that it's more likely than not.
Of course, the question was put to Rothman
during THR's roundtable, and while he didn't
enthusiastically answer in the affirmative,
he also didn't say no and it's pretty obvious
that he recognizes the value of the partnership.
The query was framed in an odd way, with the
interviewer mentioning that Sony has, quote,
"shown [it] can do Spider-Man without Marvel"
by way of the Oscar-winning animated film
Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse.
Rothman responded:
"Yes, we have.
But I agree with [Horn].
This was a classic win-win-win.
A win for Sony, a win for Disney, a win for
the fans.
The only thing I would say is that news cycles
and the rhythm of negotiations do not necessarily
overlap.
And this is, in the words of Shakespeare,
a consummation devoutly to be wished.
We would have gotten there, and the news got
ahead of some things."
There's actually quite a bit to unpack in
that statement, not the least of which is
Rothman's apparent Shakespeare fandom and
his seemingly disingenuous suggestion that
the media got ahead of the negotiations, as
most details that was being reported was coming
directly out of the mouths of the involved
parties.
In September, Sony CEO Tony Vinciquerra went
so far as to say the, quote, "door was closed"
on Spidey's return to the MCU.
He said, at the time:
"Spider-Man was fine before the event movies,
did better with the event movies, and now
that we have our own universe, he will play
off the other characters as well.
I think we're pretty capable of doing what
we have to do here."
Thankfully, the fan backlash and Holland's
timely intervention pushed the studios back
together, and now that they're back in business,
it seems unlikely that anyone involved will
be keen to go through such a trying public
ordeal again.
Feige has in the past teased his willingness
to consider crossing over or even merging
Sony's budding cinematic universe with the
MCU, because even before the whole kerfuffle,
he knew what Iger, Horn, and Rothman had to
learn the hard way: Spider-fans like their
web-slinger right where he is.
"What are you doing?"
"Oh, this is nice."
Spidey's as-yet untitled third MCU solo outing
hits the big screen on July 16, 2021.
Fingers crossed that it delivers on that Far
From Home cliffhanger.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.